i'm just gonna tell you right up front i
am exhausted i'm exhausted we're up
super late last night
12 hours of broadcasting time last night
and this thing is far from done
it is not it is not over okay this is
not over by any stretch of the
imagination so here is the latest
the trump team bill stephen and trump's
campaign manager he says that wisconsin
is a tight race and recount territory
it is indeed extremely close right now
the vote count
in wisconsin state's about 97 percent in
and joe biden has a 0.6 lead
in wisconsin he's up by about 20
000 votes in wisconsin and there are
apparently still another 100 000 votes
still left to be counted in wisconsin as
of this morning so that is where things
stand right now okay then you move on
over to pennsylvania
trump right now pennsylvania's taking
its sweet damn time for all the talk
about florida
by the way being you know florida man
and crazy state florida worked
beautifully florida reported its vote
totals when we were done
by early in the evening with florida
we'll get to florida in a second because
it shows some real pathways forward for
the republican party
in the future and some real shortcomings
for the democratic party that are quite
delicious in a variety of ways
pennsylvania trump right now is up about
10 points in pennsylvania
which is about 534 000 votes there's
still 1.6 million votes out there
to be totaled those are supposed to
break heavily democrats so it's going to
be extremely
close in pennsylvania north carolina
trump is likely to win
michigan is really really close like
separated by
12 000 votes at this point biden up 0.2
points
0.2 still about half a million votes to
be counted in michigan
trump looks like he is going to finish
off georgia so there's a lot of doubt
last night as to whether trump was
actually going to win georgia it started
off as
likely trump then it moved to lean trump
and it moved to toss-up and now it's
back to
likely trump at this point arizona is a
state that is absolutely chaotic arizona
was called very early on in the night by
fox news
they insisted that they were right and
now there's new information suggesting
that
maybe there are a bunch of maybe there
are a bunch of votes outstanding in
arizona so this is just an absolute mess
it's an absolute mess
the trump campaign nevada is extremely
tight
in fact nevada is only about eight
thousand to ten thousand votes apart and
nevada just decided they're not going to
announce any new vote totals until
tomorrow which is
this is all unconscionable and guys fix
your election systems seriously
it doesn't mean that fraud is happening
but fix your damn election systems
so stephen says michigan they're
confident in a pathway that includes the
state
nevada they're claiming victory possible
by 5 500 votes
and they're projecting optimism about
georgia and pennsylvania
as well so recounts don't as far as
wisconsin recounts don't normally
reverse 20 000 vote gaps they don't
usually it'll shift a couple hundred
votes either way
in florida for example george w bush and
al gore we had months of recounting and
it only shifted a couple hundred votes
in al gore's direction so shifting tens
of thousands of votes
on the basis of a recount is fairly
unlikely
trump campaign advisors believe that
arizona might still be in reach
for president trump on the regular
account because they're still counting
election day
voters so trump could theoretically win
at nevada and arizona and that would put
him over the top
if trump takes nevada and does not win
arizona but wins pennsylvania
then he could still be over the top so
this thing is not over yet and this is
putting aside the possibility of
lawsuits this is putting aside the
possibility of
irregularities being found right so in
other words everything is a mess
everything is an absolute mess there are
only a few things that are absolutely
clear at this point in time
one is that the polls are damned garbage
so i've been bringing the polls
consistently okay i'm bringing the polls
because i don't like operating in the
absence of data
my bias my bias in favor of data turns
out to be a bias in favor
of crap because the data here was crap
okay the data here was garbagio
and it was really garbagio on the
national level
the final real clear politics polling
average spread on this election
had joe biden up seven points nationally
seven points nationally
right now in the national vote count
total joe biden is up
by less than two points nationally less
than two
is it just over 50 and trump is at just
over 48 percent
if that is not seven points it is
certainly not ten points
i mean i'm just going to read you some
of the polls that were being trotted out
the day before the election
the economist yougov had biden up ten
points ten
ibdtipp had biden up four and that was
the most optimistic poll
for trump reuters had biden up seven
cnbc
had biden up ten quinnipiac had biden up
11 nbc news wall street journal had
biden up 10.
okay the gap is two two when you blow it
that badly on the national polling
no one should ever trust you again all
these jackasses need to learn to code
like
right now and yeah incompetence bothers
me it really really does
okay how about the battleground states
so the battleground stays
we're fairly wildly off as well in the
battleground states in the real clear
politics polling average
which was more favorable to trump than
for example the 538 polling average
in the real clear politics polling
average they had trump down in florida
by 0.9
trump will end up winning that state by
3 so not particularly close in florida
once again they blew it in florida
in north carolina the real club politics
polling average had trump up by
0.2 right now north carolina
with 95 reporting has trump up by about
two points 1.5
two points the real club politics
polling average
in arizona had biden winning that state
slim
it looks like that may hold up in
wisconsin here's a massive polling error
in wisconsin
in wisconsin the real clear politics
polling average had biden up nearly
seven
points in wisconsin nearly seven in
wisconsin right now
biden is up by less than a point in
wisconsin he's up by about 20 000 votes
total in wisconsin that is a six
point polling error in florida you are
looking at a five-point polling error
in the national numbers you're looking
at a minimum five-point polling error in
many of these polls
in eight or nine-point polling error
polling is chicken
and trail reading these people don't
know what the hell they are doing they
don't know how to pull
for trump's coalition they don't know
how to pull people who are not
college-educated white people they don't
know how to poll people who are not
picking up the phone
all of your questions about polls were
totally justified now to be fair to
myself i did say i am skeptical
that it is as far apart as the polls
were suggesting and i did say yesterday
that trump could easily win this thing
without the polls being totally wrong on
the state level
and that's true all of these margin of
error states many of them remained
margin of error
okay but something is deeply wrong in
the polling industry
something is deeply wrong in our media
industry they were suggesting that joe
biden could hide in his basement and run
away with this thing this is not a
runaway under any circumstances
not only is it not a runaway these
aren't even the worst polling errors the
worst polling errors are not
on the heavily pulled trump pad and race
the worst polling errors
were all of the polling errors in the
senate there they just blew it
and i will pat myself on the back for my
prediction on the senate i did say i
thought that republicans
would likely hold the senate so
a mess for pollsters today an absolute
mess and a big night for republicans by
the way if you're a republican
regardless of how this turns out with
trump because that's still up in the air
and he could still win this thing
depending on
how those late votes are counted
depending on whether there are lawsuits
right this is still very much up in the
air
regardless of that if you're a
republican or a conservative you should
feel very good moving forward this was
supposed to be a year like 2018
where democrats walked away with this
thing where it was a blue tidal wave
washing away all on its path where joe
biden was going to win by 10 points
nationally he was going to carry
350 electoral votes where democrats were
going to walk away with the senate
where they were going to then nuke the
filibuster and then use it to cram
through states
and cram through court packing none of
that's gonna happen now
senator mitch mcconnell is gonna be in
charge of the senate majority in all
likelihood
at this point which is a devastating
blow to the democrats
and old slo joe biden winning what may
be the narrowest electoral college
victory in american history right if
if it turns out that trump wins georgia
and he wins pennsylvania
and biden wins all the others the
election gap
is something like 270 to 268. okay that
is as close as as it is possible to get
okay that is not a massive mandate for
huge
world-beating change and joe biden is
old and daughtering and joe biden can't
hold a thought in his head
and he's going to face a fractious
coalition so if you're a conservative
regardless of what happens going forward
if you just stop time at this moment
before we even know what happens in the
presidential race last night was a very
very good night
for republicans and demonstrates full
scale that our media are garbage and
need to be replaced
forth with